FOR THE AMERICANS STILL ON THE
GROUND.
MEANTIME, BACK HERE IN THE U.S.,
RESCUE WORKERS ARE WORKING
NONSTOP IN LOUISIANA AND
MISSISSIPPI TO HELP THOSE
AFFECTED BY HURRICANE IDA AFTER
IT SLAMMED INTO LOUISIANA
YESTERDAY AS A CATEGORY 4
HURRICANE.
WIND SPEEDS TOPPING 150 MILES
PER HOUR.
HURRICANE IDA HAD THE POTENTIAL
TO BE ONE OF THE MORE POWERFUL
STORMS TO MAKE LANDFALL IN THE
U.S.
SENIOR CORRESPONDENT MIKE TOBIN
IS IN NEW ORLEANS TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, MIKE.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE KILLED BY
HURRICANE IDA HAS JUST RISEN TO
TWO AS THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT HAS
CONFIRMED A DROWNING VICTIM.
RESCUERS ARE FEARFUL THAT
RELATIVELY LOW NUMBER COULD RISE
AS THEY STRUGGLE TO REACH THE
AREAS HARDEST HIT IDA HUNDRED
IDA SLAMMED INTO LOUISIANA 16TH
ANNIVERSARY OF HURRICANE
KATRINA.
>> IT WAS LOUD.
WE COULD HEAR THE WIND AND HEAR
THINGS HITTING THE HOUSE AND
HITTING THE VEHICLE.
WE HEARD A LOT OF CRASHING
SOUND.
>> WAVES SLAMMED INTO THIS DOCK.
WREAKING HAVOC, RIPPING PIECES
OF MELTS OFF BUILDINGS AND
UPROOTING TREES IN SOUTHERN.
A LEVEE FAILED IN WILL HE FIT,
NEW ORLEANS.
LEAVING 200 PEOPLE IN IMMINENT
DANGER FROM THE HIGH WATERS
NECESSARY TAILGATING RESCUE.
SLOW MOVING STORM IS STILL
CAUSING FLOODING THROUGHOUT THE
REGION AND TORNADOES REMAIN A
THREAT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN MEETING
VIRTUALLY WITH GOVERNORS IN THE
FEMA ADMINISTRATOR NOTED THAT
MORE THAN 5,000 GUARDSMEN HAVE
BEEN CALLED CALLED.
GENERATORS ARE BEING SENT AND
DRONES BEING USED TO ASSESS
DAMAGE TO THE POWER GRID.
>> FOLKS GET KNOCKED DOWN.
WE ARE THERE TO HELP YOU GET
BACK ON YOUR FEET.
MOST IMPORTANT ELEMENT THOUGH IS
COORDINATING ALL THE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT.
>> IN NEW ORLEANS, BOURBON
STREET WAS LEFT LITTERED WITH
DEBRIS, BUILDINGS IN OTHER AREAS
OF THE CITY COLLAPSE AND HUGE
TREES WERE UPROOTED INCLUDING
ONE THAT SURVIVED HURRICANE
KATRINA.
BUT ONE THING WAS CLEAR, THIS
HURRICANE WAS NOT KATRINA.
>> SO FAR WE HAVE NOT HAD
REPORTS OF MASSIVE LOSS.
OF LIFE BUT WE DID HAVE A
TRAGEDY WHERE WE BELIEVE AN
INDIVIDUAL WAS DRIVING A CAR AND
THEREFORE DROWN.
>> THAT MAYBE DUE TO THE MORE
THAN 14 MILLION SPENT BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AFTER KATRINA
TO REBUILD THE LEVEES PROTECTING
THE CITY MAKING THEM BIGGER AND
STRONGER AND FAR MORE CAPABLE OF
WITH UNDERSTANDING HUGE
DISPLORMS ALL OF OUR LEVEE
SYSTEMS PARTICULARLY OUR FEDERAL
LEVEE SYSTEMS AND THE HURRICANE
RISK REDUCTION SYSTEM PERFORMED
MAGNIFICENTLY.
>> THE ENTERGY COMPANY SAYS
SUFFERED CATASTROPHIC DANG
DURING THE STORM.
EVEN ONE THAT SPANNED THE
MISSISSIPPI AND WITHSTOOD
KATRINA.
2 MILLION PEOPLE ARE WITHOUT
POWER.
4500 WORKERS ARE ON THE GROUND.
NO ESTIMATE FOR WHEN THE LIGHTS
WILL BE BACK ON.
BRET?
>> Bret: THAT'S A BIG DEAL,
MIKE.
THE POWER OBVIOUSLY AND HAVING
COVERED HURRICANE KATRINA 16
YEARS AGO IT'S A MUCH DIFFERENT
DEAL WITH THE LEVEES RIGHT NOW
SO THE BIG ISSUE TOWN THERE
RIGHT NOW IS POWER?
>> THE BIG ISSUE IS POWER.
ONE OF THE THINGS TO LOOK FOR,
THE PUMPS THAT DRAIN THE CITY OF
NEW ORLEANS, THOSE FUNCTION
STORM PUMPS THOSE FUNCTION BUT
THE SEWAGE PUMPS ARE DEPENDENT
ON THE POWER GRID.
YOU CAN START TO HAVE A HEALTH
EMERGENCY HERE IF THEY DON'T GET
THOSE THINGS ONLINE AND PUMPI